[Music]
hello and good afternoon Google i/o
thank you for being here thank you for
everybody on the livestream as well the
cloud is what powers an endless number
of web and mobile apps and that makes
them magical the easy access to
potentially huge amounts of compute
storage and to machine learning machine
learning api's is what makes the cloud
so special and something that you
probably should try to leverage in your
applications whenever possible my name
is Alexei and I'm a developer advocate
with Google cloud now a few questions
for you how many Android developers do
we have in the room how many web
developers anybody here has used
firebase before a good number that's
great now to be fair server-side or
otherwise back-end development can't
look tedious to some folks or just not
your cup of tea and that's fine luckily
Google has this rich open and developer
friendly cloud Google cloud platform or
GCB for short let's take a look and
start with firebase you might know
firebase for all the amazing features it
offers to enhance your client code
authentication crash reporting analytics
a be testing and the fairly recently
announced ml kit I like here to cover
everything that is not a client-side
feature and that's because firebase is a
wonderful way for Android and web
developers to leverage Google cloud
services without exposing them to all
the knobs of GCV so first there's cloud
storage this will let you manipulate
user generated files and application
files such as pictures videos think of
it as a way to save files to the cloud
for later retrieval from any authorized
device or service next cloud fire store
is the JSON database for all your
application data with real-time
notifications this may
that if a specific value changes in fire
store all your connected users can be
notified this is truly amazing cloud
functions is the easy way to add
server-side logic without having to
manage any server or any cluster simply
provide a piece of code specify the
event that triggers the execution of
that code and that could be for example
an image uploaded to a bucket or some
data changing in fire store finally ml
kid for firebase offers the ability to
add machine learning features to your
apps using api's that run either in the
cloud or on device so this includes text
recognition face detection barcode
scanning image labeling and as announced
at the technical keynote yesterday we
now have also something called Auto ml
vision edge as well as on device
translation now so why am I talking
about firebase here well it's simple
these features that have just described
are all based on Google cloud platform
or a DCP and if you only remember one
thing from this presentation it should
be that you should start with firebase
if you haven't done so already and then
grow to use GCP when you create a
firebase project it is in fact a GCP
project in every aspect resource
grouping identity management and billing
this gives you a great way to easily use
some cloud services before you graduate
into using GCP when you need to so let's
talk about Google cloud platform and
give you a sense of how it can extend
what we've just briefly seen so Google
cloud platform GCP is big I mean really
big we recently had a large event in San
Francisco called cloud next with tens of
thousands of participants with some
sessions just focusing on one specific
feature
I can't possibly be covering everything
here instead I'll try to cover what I
believe might be useful to you and give
you a few tips along the way maybe you
already have some sort of back-end
software and you're just looking for a
place to host it potentially in the
cloud so that will help you spend less
time on infrastructure management get
potentially better security and
essentially spend more time writing your
app if you are familiar with virtual
machines our compute engine is a great
environment for you compute engine or
GCE offers virtual machines discs and
networking as you can see we can go from
very small to very large amounts of CPU
and memory and that can be done using
sliders as shown here to get the perfect
configuration you can also customize
your virtual machines by adding GPUs and
cloud CPUs tensor processing units there
are many delightful features about GCE
but one of my favorites is the little
time that it takes to provision and boot
a VM but it's probably best if I show
you this in action so with that let's
switch to the demo machine and let's
create a VM
let's take most of the defaults I will
call this instance one just to make it
more fun create this in Europe and you
can have different presets you can see
the sliders that I just talked about you
can change the image the OS that you're
using there are many to choose from you
can set identity and IP API access
settings and set up a firewall to allow
or disallow which is the default any
HTTP or HTTPS traffic so let's actually
go ahead and create that instance so
we're actually provisioning here the
instance we're creating this in this
case with a Debian image with all the
defaults this one has one CPU
and I think four gigabytes of memory and
it is being created as I said in Europe
and that's it we have the VM that's
available that has an external IP
address and we can at this point SSH
into the Machine and notice I didn't
have to install anything here I'm just
using a web browser clicking through a
button and Here I am actually connected
to that machine that didn't exist a few
seconds ago so I can look at it and I
can do things such as apt-get update and
I have a fully working machine which I
can resize we can which I can delete
which it can recreate very easily so
with that let's go back to slides this
is just a few seconds to get a new
machine running in a Google Data Center
you can also do this with the command
line which means you can easily automate
the process of spinning up a machine or
multiple machines when you need them and
also shut them down
when you no longer need them there are
many features with compute engine some
that I would like to point out our live
migration which is a really a unique
feature to migrate running applications
from one machine to another preemptable
VMs offers you short-lived low-cost
virtual machines something that I would
recommend that you use if your jobs your
running processes can be interrupted we
also have some automation features such
as instance groups to administer virtual
machines in batches to achieve some
level of scalability and even to do auto
repair on production instances now let's
switch gears a little bit and talk about
storing data and databases in particular
storing data is likely to be vital for
your application you could of course
spin up a VM as we just did install your
favorite database there but here we'll
go through some cloud or GCB native
storage and they
debase options just a few to give you a
sense of what's available
chances are you have files that you
would like to store and cloud storage in
this case is a pretty obvious choice
here you can put all of your files into
one or multiple buckets and prices for
storing these varies depending on what
we call the storage class to give you a
sense of the cost you can host all of
the Internet Archive and that's about 10
petabytes for less than $100 per month
all with no disk to manage no capacity
issue to worry about so cloud storage
offers different classes as I said of
storage of these classes range from
having data as close as possible to the
end user
this is multi-regional to archival needs
the regional option here is good for
when data needs to be close to the
machine that processes it the long term
storage
near line and code line are technologies
that come with retrieval cost but are
ideal for archival data but really best
of all here is that there's a single API
to manage the lifecycle of your objects
regardless of their storage class and
you can move objects from one class to
the other so data that's no longer used
can be pushed back to something like
let's say the cold line storage now for
user data such as their profile
information they're the transactions
associated with those users you may want
to use a relational database and rather
than setting up managing and securing
your own installation you can use cloud
SQL instead this will free you up from
monitoring uptime of that database from
managing backups and from applying
security patches cloud SQL also offers
the ability to define replicas for a
highly available setup
they're currently supported databases
are MySQL Postgres and SQL Server coming
soon now no SQL databases are known to
scale regardless of the amount of data
that you throw at them and cloud files
store is no exception in fact this
database offers a JSON structure with no
schema it is strongly consistent it is
indexable and it is service meaning that
there's no infrastructure to size
provision or manage and it comes with
great SDKs for mobile and web
development if you've ever used the real
time database for firebase it's all the
good things you know with added strong
consistency better querying capabilities
multiple data centers around the world
and still the great notification and
offline capabilities that you know so
which one do you choose
well for files such as images PDF
documents it's pretty easy cloud storage
is most likely what you need for user
data transactional information good old
relational databases offered in a cloud
SQL package are probably a good choice
if you need a horizontal scalability a
schema-less database change
notifications mobile offline support
you're probably looking at cloud
firestore which you can use by the way
regardless of any other firebase
features now let's go beyond VMs and
into cloud native solutions now don't
get me wrong
virtual machines are great but
management remains your responsibility
provisioning patching the u.s. updating
it and all the security is left for you
to do which means time not spend
developing your app and also the
scalability is pretty much vertical you
can make the VM bigger but you can't
really play on the horizontal axis with
plus
during technologies and availability is
also something that is hard to add after
the fact so here we'll talk about the
cloud native approaches to running your
code kubernetes
cloud functions app engine and the newly
released cloud run product so maybe by a
show of hands here how many people know
and use docker containers great so
containers are solving the works on my
machine problem by packaging an app with
all its of its dependencies including
its runtime into a container but if you
use containers you also probably know
that that does not solve all problems
you still use you still need to schedule
and scale those containers you need to
manage their health monitor them and
more this is where schedulers such as
kubernetes
come into the picture as the inventor of
kubernetes Google offers Google kouhei's
engine or gke
a fully managed kubernetes service if
you were starting from virtual machines
or from your own servers setting up
kubernetes clusters would mean that you
have to deal with while actually
creating the virtual machines attaching
some storage installing the actual
kubernetes software setting up some
networking and security and that's a lot
of work instead with google kubernetes
engine gke it takes one command line in
just a few minutes once created the
cluster is ready to host your
containerized applications
Kuban a DS version upgrades auto repair
of failing nodes and other features are
provided out-of-the-box with GK
now while GK offers a wonderful portable
platform it comes with a requirement to
first containerize your application it
also still requires creating and
managing a cluster
with worker nodes so this isn't really
survey list which we define as something
that has no server management which is
fully secure by default this is not your
problem
and that has pay per use through
auto-scaling including scale to zero
this all sounds nice so let's take a
quick look at some GCB products that
actually qualify for this definition so
in the obvious and popular example of
service is functions as a service or
fast and cloud functions is a great
implementation of that paradigm simply
upload some code written in Python and
go and node or even in Java along with
its dependencies and they define the
event that triggers the execution of
that code the events can be anything
from an HTTP request coming in to file
being uploaded to a bucket data changing
in fire store messages being posted to a
pop subtopic cloud functions has been
used by customers to implement
everything from what we call glue code
to fully fledged micro services based
applications but enough talking let's
see cloud functions in action if we
could go back to the demo machine this
is a function written in node that will
be triggered when a file a picture in
this case is uploaded to specific bucket
so we have an event for a given bucket
for a given file that has a name so the
first thing we do here is we download
that file locally and then we use a
library called image magic to actually
do the resize of that picture and to
resize it to width of 256 pixels while
preserving the ratio we write those to a
local file and if everything goes well
we upload the result with a prefix
called resize to that same bucket
so this is the code there's some actual
metadata in terms of dependencies where
we declare dependencies on cloud storage
which we listen to and the imagemagick
version that we use we also define what
triggers the execution of this and in
this case it's an upload to this bucket
which I can click on the SEM this bucket
is empty and I suggest that we actually
upload a picture there so as we do this
we can look at the picture that was
uploaded and we can go back here and
hopefully as i refresh the bucket we
have a second picture that's there and
that has been the resize version of the
initial one so here you go these are
club functions in action and maybe we
can move now back to slides so that I
can tell you that these are available in
multiple languages as I said this was
node but you can use Python go and Java
and there are many events you can that
can trigger them not just file uploads
I think cloud functions is the easiest
way to access one of the many powerful
GCP services you know from machine
learning api's to other storage and
processing solutions now as a developer
you may want to have yet even more
freedom in the languages and the
frameworks that you use and most
importantly you may want to hand over a
carefully crafted docker image instead
of source code club run was announced
last month at the cloud next conference
and it is here to offer you a truly
serverless experience for your stateless
HTTP container images so the events are
HTTP and there needs to be no stay
preserved by the container for this to
work but if that is something that works
for you well simply build your image
upload to a registry and create a cloud
run service using that container at that
point your app is now deployed and
running in the cloud and you
forget about the provisioning and
managing a server of servers cloud run
does that for you it will automatically
and quickly scale up and down based on
the incoming traffic it will even scale
to zero meaning like no traffic no cost
but even more you can use the same
container on your own gke cluster if you
really want to understand and master the
underlying infrastructure you can do so
since this is all actually written on
top of an open source technology called
key native which provides an abstraction
layer on top of kubernetes
to provide a service environment so
choice is good right
cloud functions cloud ron well guess
what there's even more choice app engine
is the mother of surveillance at Google
and it offers the ability to build and
host entire web applications with
multiple services while still retaining
the source deployment approach all of
that obviously with serverless benefits
it comes with versioning built in it
provides out-of-the-box traffic
splitting to implement things such as
Cannery deployments or a/b testing all
at the click of a button
it also supports a long list of
languages including recent versions of
Python Java Go PHP and we recently
announced Ruby as well so at this point
you might be confused about which one to
use let me suggest that you think of it
this way which artifact
would you like to deploy would you like
to give me a function would you like to
give me an app that has multiple
services would you like to give me a
container all of these are service all
of these will scale to zero and we will
manage the entire infrastructure for you
okay so intelligence now I'm not trying
to imply here that
your apps are not build by smart
developers but instead that there's some
amazingly low-hanging fruit to make
those applications even smarter I'm
talking here mostly about machine
learning and specifically about
easy-to-use api's which any developer
can call regardless of you know their ml
skillset we call these AI building
blocks and they can grouped into the
following categories the vision API and
the video intelligence API this is the
site category we have the language
category with natural language and
translation api's and we have the
conversation category with speech to
text text-to-speech and dialogue flow
api's I mentioned ml kit for firebase
earlier what you have here is the
server-side machine learning API is that
ml kit actually uses so these api's are
available via restful endpoints making
them easy to call any part to be called
from any part of your application or
your architecture certainly if you're
building mobile Android or iOS apps ml
kit for firebase is a great way to use
these so let's look at the vision API
which is one of those api's and if we
search switch back to the demo machine I
can actually test this API right from
the browser I can upload a picture same
picture did I click on it all right let
me refresh this
and I am not a robot I hope so
I'm sending this to the vision API
asking it to return and tell me
everything it finds about that picture
from entities to landmarks to text to
web properties and entities so it has
detected that this is indeed a landmark
this is not hadam in Paris there are a
bunch of labels that it found you know
this is machine learning working for you
with a pre trained model their web
entities you know with all the things
that it finds on that picture it even
finds text if you were to zoom in you
can see that the barge here is called
nouvelle Zen there's some image
properties such as dominant colors and
last but not least there's what we call
safe search is this picture safe from a
adult spoof medical violence or racy
point of view if you have a website that
has user-generated content you probably
owe it to yourself to use something such
as the vision API to make sure
everything thats upload is actually
something you can then show to other
users all of this is actually the result
of a request asking for landmark
detection face detection we don't have
any in this one object localization we
don't have any but image properties prop
hands web detection and the result is a
JSON document which is actually parsed
and presented here in this UI but which
you typically would be using in your
application to enhance your application
so if we move it move back to slides AI
building blocks in the form of API calls
can be extremely powerful and they're
really easy to set up again they're
really just an API call
so these those API such as the vision
API are great and we call these pre
trained models meaning that Google did
the heavy lifting of training a model
leaving you with the easy prediction
part you know send an image get a result
back but what if you wanted to build
your own model
from your own data to better fit your
business needs this is where cloud auto
email comes in this is another part of
our AI building blocks Auto ml lets you
create your own custom machine learning
models with an easy-to-use graphical
interface these models can be specific
to your business needs and train with
your own data with minimal effort and
little to no coding now if you're an ml
developer a data scientist you may want
to have complete control over the
training and prediction phases but you
probably do not want to have too much
infrastructure overhead and this is
where the cloud AI platform comes in
this is Google's data science
development environment we offer a a
platform notebooks these are managed
jupiter labs notebooks integrated with
all the big data products you find in
GCP cloud CPUs and the newly announced
cloud cpu pods are hardware accelerators
designed to speed up machine learning
workloads for training and prediction
and inference program with tensorflow
deep learning VM images are
pre-configured GCE
virtual machines for deep learning
applications that use tensorflow PI
torch sight kit learn and it's trivial
to add cloud CPUs or G CPU
GPUs to these virtual machines so cloud
AI platform offers tools and products
for probably the entire lifecycle of
machine learning development if you'd
like to control everything now switching
gears a little bit here we've talked
about storing the data let's talk now
about processing your data at scale
chances are your apps web apps mobile
apps back-end apps generate some
valuable data and you would like to turn
this into insights
this takes potentially massive amounts
of compute power data processing Reese
in general and the good news is that GCP
is really great an amazing place to do
just that bigquery is an amazing product
to make sense of your data simply send
your data as much as you like along with
an SQL query the data will be processed
in just a few seconds thanks to big
queries of unique and really massive
back-end architecture cloud dataflow
is Google's implementation of the Apache
beam programming model and it offers to
process and transform massive amounts of
data both in batch and in streaming
modes Cloud Data proc is a hosted Apache
Hadoop and spark version that will spin
up a fully managed cluster in less than
90 seconds it will resize it dynamically
and offer overall great cost performance
for any hadoop or spark spark job that
you have let's take a look at a big at a
quick big query demo and move back to
the demo machine please
so 400,000 github repositories 1 billion
files and one question spaces or tabs
well we might have the answer today we
look at all of those files we just
ignore those there are less than 10
lines long and for every file we give a
plus one if it's tabs or plus one if
it's spaces and if it's a mix we just
decide to vote only one for whichever
comes more often spaces or tabs this is
the github the real the real data and
what we have in this query is the
ability to run a query against that
table and to actually for every single
line in every single file run a regular
expression counting the number of tabs
and a number of spaces and summing up
all of this so what I suggest is we
actually run this
this will process 133 gigabytes
it shouldn't take more than say 10 12 13
seconds maybe and hopefully give you an
answer down to 16 seconds 18 that's not
actually bad and so for every language
every popular language and we base the
query on the extension of the files we
found in there in the repo repos we
calculate a ratio does it have more
spaces or more tabs for every language
and you can see that Java tends to be
more about spaces where go is all about
tabs clearly so there you have it we
actually know the answer to one of the
most crucial and important question
we've had in in this ayah industry
spaces now the amazing thing here about
the query is that we've analyzed each
file again with a regular expression for
133 gigabytes of code in 10 ish seconds
like an interactive time as we call it
there is no need to go and grab a coffee
or come back the next morning to get the
answer so you can iterate them on your
queries and this is what the graph looks
like
and and credit should all go to felipe
and you can query this all the details
are there you can run the query yourself
and you can look at all the data and see
how it evolves through time but the
answer spaces so to recap we've talked
about how firebase is a great foray into
Google cloud platform we discussed
virtual machines and databases to bring
the software stacks that you love and
know to GCP next we talked about cloud
native and service and how to choose the
right solution and finally we covered
adding machine learning and data
processing to your apps and
architectures before I close let me
share a few tips and tricks as you get
started with GCB
Google Cloud console is where you will
likely spend a fair amount of time
exploring and using the platform this is
where you configure billing accounts you
create a new manage project you manage
all your GCP resources you know
regardless of the data center location
every product and every service has its
own section in the console and has
dashboards detailed configuration and
settings there is cloud Identity and
Access Management if it's a team of
people working or an entire group of
people so you set people up with the
right permissions and there's even a
mobile app for monitoring and managing
your apps and resources on the go so
while the console is super powerful
flexible you can also do everything with
the g-cloud command line so for every
action in the console there's a g-cloud
equivalent so g-cloud is our scriptable
and almighty CLI cloud shell is a shell
environment hosted on GCP and it manages
your projects and resources it's
accessible from a web browser and it's
powered by a small virtual machine with
persistent disk space and up-to-date
store a software you know good docker
containers
I mean compilers all of these things for
all your development needs and it even
comes with a web code editor so GCP
resources are the fundamental components
that make up Google cloud services
typical examples include compute engine
virtual machines cloud pub/sub topics
cloud storage buckets called functions
and so forth and those resources can be
organized into projects and folders this
means for instance that once you delete
a project all the resources attached to
it can also be deleted which is a great
way to keep a clean environment and to
keep your cost under control so what do
you need to get started well the first
thing you need is a Google account
you can create a new Google account or
you can use an existing one such as your
Gmail account I would recommend that you
enable billing for your project and then
you sign up for the $300 free trial to
get started at no charge if you do not
sign up for the free trial you can still
benefit from the fairly generous always
frites here that GCP offers so $300 is
actually quite a bit of money and enough
to kick the tires of GCP in a number of
ways you could have six VMs running for
one year they're fairly small but that's
six of them or a four node cluster of
bigger VMs for a container engine a gke
cluster for three months non-stop or you
could store 10 terabytes in a multi
regional storage bucket which is the
best performing storage class for one
month the billing section of the cloud
console is where you manage billing
accounts and your link project to those
billing accounts and a billing account
is really a payment method one or more
credit cards or bank account details you
can change the billing account for a
given project at any point of time and
you could set budget alerts that helps
you manage cost and setup triggered
actions for projects or accounts as well
you can also generate billing exports as
well as reports to better understand
your span this is important when you
start using cloud at scale so beyond the
web console the command-line tools GCP
also comes with a number of built in
additional tools to start with every
project comes with a private by default
get repo called cloud source
repositories which is free for up to
five users and 50 gigabytes of storage
so staying with resources that are
private to your projects and teams GCP
also comes with container repository to
store your container images once your
container image is in the repo and that
means it's on Google's Network which
means in turn that the deploy
to gke and plot run are really fast and
when it comes to building container
images or any code for that matter
there's cloud bill a fully managed CI CD
platform this includes building as the
name implies but also deploying two VMs
to gke
and to service products now product
naming for us and for everybody is hard
but remembering all of these names can
be overwhelming for you as well
so here's a cheat sheet with concise
definitions of all products GCP and four
words or less and this covers every
product I've talked about but everyone
also I didn't talk about now as I come
to the end of this session I'd like to
do a shameless plug for a series of
videos on the Google cloud YouTube
channel called no surprise GCB
essentials the goal here is to cover in
fairly short episodes something that is
helpful for people who are actually
getting started with Google cloud
platform check out the video please and
if you like them do subscribe so that
was a lot of ground covered I'm leaving
you with some links including the one
for the four words or less I hope this
was time well spent for you I hope you
will consider bringing the awesomeness
of GCB to your existing and upcoming
apps thank you to everybody on the
livestream and for everybody feel free
to hit me up on Twitter thank you very
much
[Music]